on ouvre une page santé les
établissements français du sang tire la
sonnette d'alarmé depuis quelques
semaines les donneurs se font de plus en
plus rares en cause la crise sanitaire
qui fait peur peur de la contamination
et pourtant tout se fait dans le plus
grand respect des gestes barrières et le
personnel est là pour rassurer les
donneurs
reportage à la maison du sang à tour
paul boyer cela fait plus de vingt ans
que frédéric fait don de son sang pour
les hôpitaux en bonne santé et désireux
d'aider c'est d'autant plus important
pour lui de le faire en période de crise
sanitaire les hôpitaux ont toujours
besoin de sang et moi je suis en bonne
santé je
je suis du groupe o positif donc
aucun souci c'est important d'aider les
malades et le personnel soignant surtout
en ce moment
aujourd'hui une cinquantaine de donneurs
ont défilé à la maison du sang de tours
un peu en dessous des jauges quotidienne
marine pas inquiet du tout à fait le
déplacement plein régulièrement depuis
une dizaine d'années dès que j'ai pu
toucher les données c'est très important
parce que lui sinon on n'a pas assez
pour eux pour les hôpitaux donc
commissions souvent crise shenzhen et
deux donneurs qui n'ont pas hésité une
seconde à venir malgré le coc vide
depuis quelques jours l'établissement
français du sang à l'aide sur une nette
diminution des dons à l'échelle
régionale
selon l'organisme cela est dû à une
anxiété généralisée des futurs donneurs
qui n'osent plus venir à cause de la
pandémie nous dans notre région au lieu
d'être sur une semaine à 9000 dont on
est on est en train de descendre petit à
petit en plus lundi prochain c'est le
lundi de pâques donc un jour de moins
deux collègues donc c'est vrai que même
sur la région on se fait un peu peur
pour prendre rendez vous il faut se
rendre sur internet ou bien appeler par
téléphone après chaque passage de
patients le fauteuil est minutieusement
nettoyer de quoi rassurer les futurs
donneurs